christian drosten vom star biologen zum
buhmann der nation degradiert ganz vorne
mit dabei
die bild -zeitung die einen medialen
angriff auf den wissenschaftsbetrieb
gestartet hat dabei ist es der kern des
forschungs betriebes sich zu irren und
sich zu korrigieren aber und das ist der
punkt am ende entstehen belegte
erkenntnisse und die sind dann ziemlich
unumstößlich da können dann die bild
oder tram proben wie sie wollen
die erde dreht sich um die sonne und
auch was die auswirkung von dawson's
studie angeht da wird sich die bild
-zeitung erwiesenermaßen gewaltig klicks
um science-fiction
hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen clixoom gibt es übrigens auch
als podcast der link zur spotify und
apple podcast ist unten in der video
beschreibung wieder einmal will die bild
zeitung einen skandal aufgedeckt haben
diesmal geht es um eine studie des
biologen christian drosten diese sei
zitat grob falsch und der experte habe
damit zitat komplett daneben gelegen
inhaltlich ging es in den untersuchungen
von christian drosten und seinem team um
die viruslast bei kindern sind kinder
weniger gefährdet und ansteckend als
andere altersgruppen demnach kann es
statistisch gesehen nicht ausgeschlossen
werden dass kinder das virus übertragen
die bild zeitung hat damit den
vermeintlichen schuldigen ausgemacht die
politik habe sich aufgrund dorstens
aussagen gegen eine zeitnahe und
unbegrenzte wiedereröffnung von schulen
und kindergärten ausgesprochen dazu
heißt es in der bild fiel die deutsche
schulpolitik einer falschen studie zum
opfer dafür hatte die bild angeblich
auch zeugen vier wissenschaftler die vor
allem die statistischen methoden von
christian drosten und seinem team
kritisieren und nicht nur das genau eine
stunde zeit hatte die bild redaktion dem
berliner biologen dann gegeben um zu den
vorwürfen aus der bild redaktion
stellung zu nehmen
der aber lässt sich nicht beeindrucken
und twitterte interessant die wild plant
eine tendenziöse berichterstattung über
unsere vor publikation zu virus lasten
und bemüht dabei zitat fetzen von
wissenschaftlern ohne zusammenhang ich
soll innerhalb von einer stunde stellung
nehmen ich habe besseres zutun der bild
artikeln ging also raus und es dauerte
nicht lange bis sich die angeblichen
zeugen davon distanzierten so unter
anderem der us statistiker jörg steuer
der dann erklärte dass seine kritischen
äußerungen zu den statistischen methoden
keineswegs eine manipulation von daten
unterstellt sogar christian drosten
selbst hatte immer wieder betont dass
sein forschungsteam zitat grobe und
einfache statistische methoden angewandt
hatte alle seine schlussfolgerungen legt
der berliner biologe ausführlich dar und
die vergangenheit zeigt dass er bereit
ist diese zu ändern wie übrigens die
meisten wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wenn es zeit dafür ist
heißt also sobald es neue erkenntnisse
aus der wissenschaft gibt das zeigt wie
wissenschaft funktioniert es gehört zu
ihrem kern immer weiter nach neuen
erkenntnissen zu suchen und diese suche
auch nicht aufzugeben und dabei immer
weiter und tiefer in ein thema wie zum
beispiel auch beim klimawandel
einzudringen
dabei darf man eine sache nicht
vergessen forschende sind auch nur
menschen sie irren sich und sie lernen
dazu sie korrigieren sich und genau
dafür sind die preprint veröffentlichung
um die es hier geht veröffentlichung ist
auch eigentlich das falsche wort sie
werden auf die print server gelegt damit
sie in der wissenschafts community
diskutiert werden und in frage gestellt
werden und dann werden sie auch geändert
und manchmal werden die kritiker und
kritikerinnen zum mit autorin oder
autoren das ist alles andere als ein
problem das es wissenschaft vor allem
nicht in der aktuellen situation das
phänomen corona es gerade einmal seit
einem halben jahr thema für uns das
problem dabei ist die reaktion der
politik und vielen medien das muss man
sich mal vorstellen mittlerweile
bekommen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler morddrohungen weil sie
für die korona maßnahmen verantwortlich
gemacht werden weil sie angeblich
übertreiben weil sie an einem tag dies
sagen und am nächsten tag das so ärgert
sich beispielsweise fdp chef christian
lindner über dieses zitat hin und her
ebenso nrw-ministerpräsident armin
laschet der fast beleidigt wird also das
hier sagt zitat wenn alle paar tage die
meinung geändert wird ist das auch für
politik schwierig da haben zwei etwas
nicht verstanden und eben auch die bild
zeitung der neue erkenntnisse aus der
forschung fallen nicht vom himmel
dem voran geht ein oft sehr langwieriger
prozess finden experimente statt oder
ist
werden studien gemacht untersuchungen
oder manchmal wird auch einfach nur
nachgedacht und hergeleitet und die
daraus gewonnenen erkenntnisse müssen
interpretiert werden dann laufen weitere
untersuchungen überlegungen und so
weiter die diese interpretationen
wiederum hinterfragen und so neue daten
generiert werden extrem wichtig hier
hinterfragen es wird nicht nach
bestätigung gesucht sondern nach
schwachpunkten fehlern diskussionen und
auch hart geführte diskussionen haben
eine enorm große bedeutung in der
wissenschaft und uns völlig normal dass
kolleginnen und kollegen aus der
wissenschaft neu veröffentlichte studien
also als prinz kritisieren und damit
studienergebnisse in frage stellen genau
das macht gute wissenschaftliche praxis
aus deshalb sind studien dann wenn sie
veröffentlicht werden qualitativ so
hochwertig letztlich muss sich das erst
einem kollegen erklären leider leiter
eines großen bedeutenden regional
fensters eines privatsenders er war
klima skeptiker und forderte dass diese
ganzen studien zum klimawandel ja auch
mal in frage gestellt werden müssten ich
musste erst mal erklären dass das
ausnahmslos bei jeder schule schon
geschehen war genauso wie jetzt posten
bei jeder und genau das ist das prinzip
von wissenschaft es ist schade dass das
selbst gestandene journalisten wie jetzt
auch julian reichelt von der bild
offenbar gar nicht wissen und der grund
für dieses vorgehen in der wissenschaft
ist ganz einfach nur wenn ergebnisse
reproduzierbar sind gelten sie als
allgemein anerkannt und das ist ein sehr
wichtiges kriterium andere
forschungsteams arbeiten dafür mit
denselben methoden und daten und müssen
unter diesen umständen dann zwingend auf
dieselben ergebnisse kommen sprich
erstens forschungsergebnisse sind immer
wenn sie überprüft und das am besten
mehrfach sehr verlässlich das ist die
selbstkontrolle der wissenschaft
zweitens wie sie dann zu interpretieren
sind das ist eine zweite frage und
braucht oft länger bis hier eine
erkenntnis gewonnen wird und sich die
fachwelt einig ist kona wird das noch
dauern
vor allem bei der ansteckung durch
kinder vor allem wird das nicht eine
einzelne studie seien sondern viele bei
den aerosolen
da ist es genauso gelaufen und jetzt
sehen wir inzwischen klarer
gerade hat noch eine aktuelle
untersuchung gezeigt dass es ein äußerst
kompliziertes unterfangen ist
wissenschaftlich konsens zu finden also
übereinstimmung
konkret hat ein internationales
forschungsteam da
das größte experiment seiner art zum
thema gestartet die große frage lautete
wie einig sind sich wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler
wenn sie auf der basis ein und derselben
daten schlüsse ziehen sollen dafür
wurden insgesamt 70 forschungsteams
weltweit hirnscans von 108
versuchspersonen vorgelegt die alle die
hirnaktivität der probanden und
probanden bei bestimmten entscheidungen
zeigt die fachleute sollten diese daten
mit hilfe ihrer standardmethoden
analysieren und die vorgegebenen
hypothesen prüfen
das auswertungs team bekam nach drei
monaten nicht nur die jeweiligen
ergebnisse für die neun verschiedenen
hypothesen zurück mit dabei waren auch
informationen darüber wie die
kolleginnen und kollegen bei der analyse
vorgegangen waren und zu welchen
zwischenergebnissen die teams jeweils
gekommen waren
das ergebnis war überraschend denn die
verschiedenen gruppen stimmten nicht nur
hinsichtlich der aufbereiteten daten
weitestgehend über ein
auch die erzählten zwischenergebnisse
waren sich sehr ähnlich das liegt
einfach daran dass es bei wissenschaft
einen strengen festgelegten logischen
ablauf zur überprüfung von
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen gibt
und dieser komplett wertfreie logische
weg erlaubt die gewinnung von wirklichen
erkenntnissen die die wirklichkeit sehr
gut darstellen
anders dagegen bei den
schlussfolgerungen die die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus ihren auswertungen gezogen hatten
bei fünf der insgesamt neun hypothesen
stimmten die meinungen nicht überein
nach ansicht der fachleute ist das
darauf begründet dass komplexe
ergebnisse auf einfache ja nein
entscheidungen reduziert werden müssen
dazu simon eickhoff vom
forschungszentrum jülich der an der
studie beteiligt war
dieses spezielle problem der analyse
betrifft alle bereiche in denen mit hoch
komplexen daten gearbeitet wird die am
ende auf ein nacktes jahr ein resultat
reduziert werden müssen heisst also im
klartext auch wenn es identische
ausgangsdaten gibt und eine festgelegte
fragestellung kommt es zu erheblichen
abweichungen bei der interpretation der
daten
das internationale forschungsteam hält
dazu als ergebnis fest dieser prozess
der selbstreflektion und der
kontinuierlichen verbesserung der
eigenen methoden ist einzigartig und
zeichnet die wissenschaft aus denn das
ist die folge solange die
interpretationen so unterschiedlich sind
zum beispiel ob kinder nun genauso
ansteckend sind oder eben
wird so lange geforscht widerlegt und
überprüft bis durch diesen prozess und
die erfahrungen die man zb mit der
anwendung der forschungsergebnisse
gemacht hat zu einem erfahrungsschatz
führen der nicht mehr viel
interpretationsspielraum lässt bei der
ansteckung über aerosole bykow mit 19
war das ein langer weg auf dem es immer
mehr studien gab die sich eben zum teil
wieder sprachen inzwischen ist es
bestätigt das aerosol eine erhebliche
rolle spielen eine einzelne studie hätte
diese erkenntnisse nicht bieten können
viele tun es aber am ende fest steht
christian drosten macht vieles richtig
er sorgt für transparenz und versucht
seine erklärungen anschaulich zu
untermauern um so vertrauen in die
forschung zu schaffen doch klar ist auch
dass wir vor allem in sachen koop mit 19
noch ganz am anfang eines langen
erkenntnisprozess stehen erst galt die
erkrankung als reine lungenkrankheit
mittlerweile wissen wir dass das virus
vor fast keinem organ im menschlichen
körper halt macht anfangs kalten kinder
als weitgehend unempfindlich dann gab es
in diensten für seltene komplikationen
und auch was den ursprung von saas kopf
2 angeht stehen wir noch ganz am anfang
ebenso wenig wissen wir wie der weitere
verlauf der pandemie sein wird doch
alles steht im krassen gegensatz zu
einem sehr starken öffentlichen
interesse und zwar an auch denjenigen
erkenntnissen die die wissenschafts
community selbst als vorläufig
bezeichnet und das ist ein relativ neues
phänomen
denn noch vor 20 jahren bekam
öffentlichkeit und medien erst nach
einiger zeit etwas von den aktuellsten
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen mit
schon damals natürlich diskutierten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
über ihre arbeit auch über den
sogenannten peer review prozess ein
wichtiges instrument in der forschung
hierbei wird eine arbeit zur
veröffentlichung eingereicht doch zuvor
14 begutachtet und zwar von einer
auswahl an unabhängigen expertinnen und
experten an die breite öffentlichkeit
gelangten die resultate dann meist erst
ganz am ende dieses langwierigen
prozesses das ist heute anders denn die
meisten fachleute stellen ihre
ergebnisse und daten online sogar
geplante studiendesigns schaffen es ins
netz forschungsteams ermöglicht es damit
ihren kolleginnen und kollegen dass
diese ausführlich und offen diskutiert
werden können diese so genannte oben
science also offene wissenschaft ist
einer der wichtigsten fortschritte der
wissenschaft in diesem jahrhundert
kritik
in diesem bereich also völlig normal ja
sogar erwünscht nur was nicht erwünscht
und sogar kontraproduktiv ist diese
zwischenergebnisse zu veröffentlichen
und den eindruck zu erwecken dass er
erstens ein wissenschaftler die wahrheit
verkünden will
und irgendeine agenda hat und zum
zweiten diese zwischenergebnisse als
ergebnisse zu verkünden
auch wir berichten hier über prix prinz
aber wir sagen immer dazu dass sie eben
noch nicht peer reviewed sind und
deshalb noch nicht final sind und es
eine unsicherheit gibt bis vor wenigen
monaten hätten vermutlich auch nur
einige forscherinnen und forscher die
arbeit von christian drosten zur
viruslast von kindern entdeckt jetzt
werden solche studie neben aber auch
direkt in den medien diskutiert erst
einmal spricht ja auch nichts dagegen
doch hierbei muss eines ganz klar sein
diese ergebnisse sind vorläufig und von
seiten der wissenschaft community nicht
zur medialen verbreitung gedacht
jedenfalls nicht um sie zu kritisieren
sie sind ja noch gar nicht fertig das
machen dann die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler an dieser stelle und
ehrlich gesagt haben wir medien gar
nicht die kompetenz dazu also auch ich
würde ihm her dass never ever anmaßen
doch die korona pandemie setzt diese
regeln offenbar außer kraft christian
drosten jedenfalls erklärt in seinem
podcast dass er zusammen mit seinem team
ganz bewusst grobe statistische methoden
angewandt habe damit habe man erste
ansatzpunkte identifizieren wollen wo
man feinere analytik einsetzen können
dennoch sei die aussage seiner arbeit
klar auch wenn er die kritik der
statistiker nachvollziehen kann es gibt
auch bei kindern sehr hohe virus lasten
die kritikpunkte haben aber für die
medizinische interpretation die
bedeutung der daten keinem konsequenz
durch den input seiner kolleginnen und
kollegen planen nun den statistischen
teil der auswertung neu zu konzentrieren
an dieser stelle muss man eines
festhalten der wissenschaftler hat mut
fehler einzugestehen und hat in den
vergangenen monaten mehrmals bewiesen
dass er sich nicht so fallen dafür ist
die grenzen seines wissens aufzuzeigen
dennoch schreibt die bild schulen und
kitas wegen falscher corona studie dicht
liebe bild wie soll man das verstehen
die schulen und kitas in deutschland
wurden bereits ab dem 16 märz 2020
geschlossen
die arbeit von christian drosten und
seinem team wurde in einer vorabversion
erst anderthalb monate später am 29
april 2020 veröffentlicht also
wenn das kein verschwörungs realismus
ist diese entwicklung jedenfalls
verändern
jedenfalls nicht nur die wissenschaft
sondern auch die politik beide seiten
können lernen vor publikationen die sich
noch in dem prozess der
wissenschaftlichen bewertung befinden
dürfen nicht als grundlage für
politische entscheidungen erhalten
forscherinnen und forscher müssen mit
transparent und anschaulichkeit die ihre
erklärung untermauern und somit dazu
beitragen dass das vertrauen der
menschen in die wissenschaft nicht
leidet christian drosten warum ihm die
politiker bei corona vertrauen mit mega
viel infos noch zu christian drosten
anklicken anschauen und dr wissenschaft
abonnieren einer meiner absoluten
lieblings kanäle bis dann bleibt dran